- Ласкаво просимо до курсу «Розуміння
квантової інформації та обчислень».
Мене звати Джон Ватрус, я технічний директор
IBM Quantum Education.
Мета цього курсу — дати тобі
ґрунтовне розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень, а це означає занурення
в технічні деталі
квантової інформації та вивчення того, як квантові
обчислення насправді працюють, що вони можуть і чого не можуть.
Якщо ти ще не дивився
оглядове відео до цього курсу, раджу обов'язково переглянути його.
У тому відео ти знайдеш інформацію про те, яка підготовка
рекомендована для цього курсу, а також план тем, які будуть розглянуті.
Також обов'язково ознайомся
з підручником Qiskit, який охоплює той самий
матеріал, що й ця серія відео, але у письмовій формі,
а ще він містить
інтерактивні компоненти та інтерфейси до апаратного і програмного забезпечення, які допоможуть тобі краще зрозуміти
квантову інформацію та обчислення. Посилання на оглядове відео і підручник Qiskit
ти знайдеш в описі.
Це урок перший
першого розділу курсу.
Перший розділ охоплює основи
квантової інформації, і в першому уроці ми зосередимося на тому, як
працює квантова інформація
для одиночних систем, тобто коли в нас є
лише одна фізична система або пристрій певного типу, що
зберігає квантову інформацію,
і ми розглядаємо, як ця
одна система або пристрій працює ізольовано.
У наступному уроці ми розглянемо, як
квантова інформація працює, коли в нас є кілька систем, і це дозволить нам
описати цікаві
та важливі концепції, такі як квантові алгоритми, що використовують кілька qubits,
та квантові протоколи,
де кілька учасників обробляють квантову інформацію і передають її один одному.
Але перш ніж переходити до цих обговорень, варто почати з
порівняно простого випадку — одиночної системи в ізоляції,
частково тому, що добре починати з простого, але ще й тому, що, як ми побачимо, опис того, як
працює квантова інформація
для одиночних систем в ізоляції, дуже природно і логічно веде до опису того, як
для множинних систем.
Ось короткий огляд уроку.
Ми почнемо з обговорення
класичної інформації.
Мета цього уроку — не пояснити, як
працює класична інформація, а пояснити, як
працює квантова інформація,
але щоб пояснити, як
працює квантова інформація, дуже корисно почати
з класичної інформації і використовувати її як
знайому точку відліку
під час обговорення квантової інформації.
На математичному рівні квантова і класична інформація мають доволі схожі описи, хоча, звісно, є деякі ключові відмінності.
Насправді, квантова інформація
зовсім не відокремлена від класичної.
Це розширення
класичної інформації.
Суть полягає в тому,
що, принаймні на мій погляд, ти справді не можеш
зрозуміти квантову інформацію, якщо не розумієш
класичну,
тому починати з класичної
інформації цілком логічно.
Я розраховую, що цей
матеріал буде знайомий деяким глядачам, але навіть якщо ти з ним знайомий, я не рекомендую пропускати його.
Окрім висвітлення аспектів класичної інформації, найбільш релевантних для
розуміння квантової інформації, ми введемо тут
нотацію Дірака,
яка є стандартним способом,
яким ми будемо описувати вектори і
матриці впродовж усього курсу.
Як виявляється, нотація Дірака не є
специфічною для квантової інформації.
Її можна так само застосовувати в контексті класичної інформації, а також у багатьох інших ситуаціях, де виникають вектори та матриці.
Потім ми перейдемо до квантової інформації, і зокрема розглянемо
представлення квантових станів у вигляді векторів,
простий тип вимірювання, який називається вимірюванням у стандартному базисі, та унітарні операції, які описують дискретні зміни в часі
квантових систем.
Знову ж таки, все це в контексті
одиночних систем.
Перш ніж ми почнемо власне урок, буде корисно уточнити, що насправді існують два описи
квантової інформації: спрощений опис, на якому ми й зосередимося в цьому уроці,
а також протягом усього першого розділу, і загальний опис, який розглядається в пізнішому розділі, а саме в
третьому розділі курсу.
Спрощений опис,
як і слідує з назви, є простішим і
зазвичай вивчається першим.
У спрощеному описі, як я вже зазначив, квантові стани представляються векторами, а операції представляються
унітарними матрицями.
Цього опису квантової
інформації достатньо для розуміння
більшості квантових алгоритмів, наприклад,
тож він не є надмірно спрощеним — це справжній підхід.
Однак, як ми
виявимо в процесі, він має певні обмеження.
Наприклад, якщо ми хочемо
змоделювати вплив шумів на квантові системи, цей опис виявляється недостатнім.
WEBVTT
Загальний опис, з іншого
боку, є більш загальним і зрештою більш
потужним у математичному сенсі.
У цьому описі квантові стани представляються спеціальним класом матриць,
які називаються матрицями густини,
а також можна описати більш загальний клас
вимірювань і операцій, включаючи
шуми, наприклад.
Він повністю узгоджується зі
спрощеним описом, і фактично ти можеш розглядати
спрощений опис
як окремий випадок
загального опису, який також включає класичну інформацію як окремий випадок.
Він також справді дуже
красивий у своїй цілісності, тому я настійно рекомендую тобі ознайомитися з цим загальним описом
коли прийде час, але спрощений опис є більш природним місцем для початку, тому саме з нього ми і почнемо.
Ми почнемо з розмови про класичну інформацію, звертаючи увагу на ті аспекти
класичної інформації, які найбільш релевантні
для квантової інформації,
та на те, як вона описується
математично.
Уяви, що в нас є
фізична система або пристрій певного типу, що зберігає інформацію.
Ми назвемо цю систему X, але в цій назві
немає нічого особливого.
Ми могли б вибрати будь-яку іншу
назву за бажанням, але просто щоб якось назвати,
будемо називати систему X.
Ми зробимо припущення щодо X, а саме що існує
скінченна множина класичних станів, у яких X може перебувати
в будь-який момент часу.
Тут, коли я говорю про класичний стан, я маю на увазі конфігурацію системи, яку можна однозначно розпізнати і
описати
без будь-якої невизначеності чи помилки.
Насправді, це те, про що можна думати інтуїтивно. На математичному рівні ми просто визначаємо
множину класичних станів,
вибираємо її так, як хочемо, або так, як найкраще
описує пристрій, з яким ми працюємо.
Назвемо цю множину класичних станів сигма, і знову підкреслю,
що ми припускаємо, що сигма є скінченною множиною.
Множина класичних
станів цієї системи X не є нескінченно великою, як
множина всіх натуральних чисел.
Вона скінченна, і це лише
припущення, яке ми робимо.
Наприклад, може бути, що X — це біт, у цьому разі множина класичних станів — це множина, що містить два
елементи: нуль і один.
Іноді ми називаємо цю
множину бінарним алфавітом.
Інший приклад: X — це
звичайний шестигранний кубик, у цьому разі класичні стани — це числа від одного до шести.
Звісно, ми говоримо тут
про абстракцію.
Реальний шестигранний кубик може
мати багато різних атрибутів, наприклад точне
положення, орієнтацію,
температуру тощо. Але щодо тієї інформації, яка зазвичай найбільш релевантна, коли ми говоримо про шестигранний кубик,
класичні стани — це
числа від одного до шести, позначені кількістю крапок на тій стороні кубика, яка дивиться вгору.
Якщо X — це перемикач на
звичайному електричному вентиляторі, який може бути у тебе вдома, то можливо класичні стани —
це положення: висока,
середня, низька швидкість і вимкнено.
Це лише приклади. Можна уявити системи з іншими множинами класичних
станів, але, сподіваємося, вони передають ідею
про те, що це поняття класичного стану є чимось знайомим і може бути зрозуміле в простих та інтуїтивних термінах.
Математично кажучи, множина класичних станів
— це просто скінченна множина, і, звичайно, ця множина також має
бути непорожньою.
Має існувати хоча б
один класичний стан, у якому може перебувати система, і має бути щонайменше два класичні стани,
якщо система взагалі буде корисною для зберігання інформації.
Тепер, у деяких ситуаціях ми можемо знати, що X перебуває
в якомусь конкретному стані, але в багатьох ситуаціях,
які виникають у контексті
обробки інформації, може бути невизначеність щодо класичного стану системи в конкретний момент,
так що кожен можливий класичний стан має певну пов'язану з ним ймовірність.
Наприклад, якщо X — це біт, то можливо X перебуває в класичному стані нуль
з ймовірністю три чверті, а в стані один
— з ймовірністю одна чверть.
Ми будемо називати це
імовірнісним станом, і ми можемо виразити
цей імовірнісний стан, як ти бачиш тут,
просто вказавши, якими є
ймовірності для різних класичних станів.
Більш стислий спосіб виразити
цей імовірнісний стан — за допомогою вектора, а саме того представлення,
яке ти бачиш тут
— це стовпцевий вектор, і цей вектор показує,
якими є ймовірності для двох можливих класичних станів.
Конкретніше, перший елемент показує,
якою є ймовірність того, що X перебуває в стані нуль, а другий елемент говорить
нам, якою є ймовірність
того, що система перебуває в стані один. Це просто природний спосіб впорядкування бінарного алфавіту,
або принаймні так
нас навчили це робити. Нуль — перший, один — другий.
Далі ми будемо використовувати
термін «вектор ймовірностей» для позначення такого вектора.
WEBVTT
Зокрема, це вектор, усі елементи якого є
невід'ємними дійсними числами, а сума
елементів дорівнює одиниці,
тому має сенс розглядати
ці елементи як ймовірності.
У цьому прикладі лише два елементи, тому що є лише два
класичні стани системи, про яку ми говоримо,
але загалом елементів може
бути будь-яка кількість з урахуванням того,
що є по одному елементу для кожного класичного стану
будь-якої системи, про яку ми говоримо.
Ми продовжимо
обговорення класичної інформації, векторів ймовірностей тощо через мить, але спочатку буде дуже корисно
ввести деякі позначення
для опису векторів, відомі як нотація Дірака.
Насправді, це лише перша
частина нотації Дірака.
Є ще кілька інших
аспектів нотації Дірака, які ми побачимо трохи
пізніше в уроці.
Ця нотація буде
досить центральною для того, як ми описуємо квантову інформацію, тому важливо
зрозуміти, як вона працює,
але на щастя, вона дуже проста і справді не має
нічого специфічного для квантової інформації,
тому ми можемо ввести її зараз
у знайомому контексті класичної інформації.
Як і раніше, ми припускаємо, що маємо множину сигма
класичних станів деякої системи, і припустимо
що ми маємо впорядкування
цих класичних станів, так само як ми говорили про
впорядкування бінарного алфавіту
у попередньому прикладі. Інший спосіб сказати це —
що елементи сигма ставляться у відповідність
цілим числам
від одного до скількох
елементів міститься в сигма, що й означає ця нотація тут із двома вертикальними рисками навколо сигма.
Це кількість
елементів у множині сигма.
Отже, є перший стан,
другий стан і так далі.
Конкретне впорядкування або
відповідність, яку ми вибираємо, насправді не матиме великого значення.
Дійсно важливо, щоб
у нас було впорядкування і ми його дотримувалися.
Для багатьох множин класичних станів,
з якими ми зустрінемося, буде стандартне впорядкування, як і в нас є для
бінарного алфавіту,
а якщо стандартного впорядкування немає, ми можемо просто вибрати одне.
Але яким би воно не було, розуміється, що ми його дотримуємося.
Тепер ось нотація,
яку ми вводимо.
Для будь-якого вибору класичного
стану a з нашої множини сигма ми записуємо ось це, що читається як кет a,
маючи на увазі стовпцевий вектор,
у якому одиниця стоїть на позиції, що відповідає a, а на всіх інших позиціях — нулі.
Наприклад, якщо ми повернемося
до бінарного алфавіту, який, як ти, мабуть, здогадався, є дуже важливим прикладом,
до якого ми будемо повертатися знову і знову. Тоді кет нуль і кет один — це вектори, визначені тут.
Кет нуль — це вектор,
у якому одиниця стоїть на позиції, що відповідає класичному стану нуль, тобто на першій позиції,
а на всіх інших позиціях — нулі, і в цьому випадку
є лише одна інша позиція.
Аналогічно, кет один — це
ось цей вектор, де одиниця стоїть на позиції, що відповідає одиниці,
тобто на другій позиції, а на всіх інших позиціях — нулі, яких, знову ж таки, лише одна.
Ось інший приклад. У цьому прикладі маємо множину класичних станів сигма, що відповідає чотирьом мастям
у стандартній колоді карт: трефи, бубни, червоні та піки.
У цьому випадку насправді немає
загальноприйнятого впорядкування цих мастей.
Для багатьох карткових ігор впорядкування взагалі немає. Це просто чотири різні масті, і це все, що має значення, а є різні карткові
ігри, де ці масті впорядковуються
по-різному, але це не має особливого значення.
Ми можемо просто вибрати
впорядкування, як те, що ти бачиш тут.
Тут використовується алфавітне впорядкування відповідно до назв цих чотирьох мастей, написаних англійською мовою,
припускаючи, що ми вибрали
це конкретне впорядкування, ми визначаємо ці чотири вектори: кет треф, кет бубен,
кет червоних та кет пік,
як ти бачиш тут, і ці вектори відповідають
загальному опису, який ти бачиш вгорі.
З огляду на те, що ми вибрали
це конкретне впорядкування для цих чотирьох мастей.
Ми можемо зробити те саме для будь-якої множини класичних станів,
яку ми вибираємо.
Пам'ятаючи, що множина класичних
станів завжди означає скінченну і непорожню множину.
Вектори такого вигляду
називаються векторами стандартного базису, і це дуже основний факт про вектори: будь-який вектор можна
виразити єдиним чином
як лінійну комбінацію
векторів стандартного базису.
Наприклад, повертаючись до прикладу з хвилину тому, вектор ймовірностей,
який ми бачили, можна виразити
як ти бачиш тут. Це в основному лише альтернативний спосіб виразити вектори,
який буде дуже зручним з кількох причин надалі.
WEBVTT
І маючи тепер цю нотацію в руках, повернімося до обговорення
класичної інформації і, зокрема, імовірнісних станів.
І розглянемо, що відбувається,
коли ми вимірюємо систему, поки вона перебуває в якомусь імовірнісному стані.
Ми могли б зазвичай і не
говорити про вимірювання або акт вимірювання
чогось у класичному контексті, але цей термін має сенс.
По суті, коли ми говоримо
про вимірювання системи X в цьому контексті, ми просто маємо на увазі, що ми дивимося на неї і розпізнаємо будь-який стан, у якому вона перебуває.
Звичайно, коли ми дивимося на систему, ми не бачимо імовірнісний стан, ми бачимо класичний стан,
і конкретний
класичний стан, який ми бачимо, — це той, який ми можемо
уявити, вибраний випадково відповідно до ймовірностей.
Тепер ти можеш заперечити на
філософських підставах проти ідеї, що класичний стан, який ми бачимо, якимось чином вибирається випадково
в момент, коли ми вимірюємо або дивимося на систему, система просто перебувала в якомусь конкретному
класичному стані весь час
і ми просто
дізналися, яким був цей стан, але заради роздумів про математичну
основу, з якою ми працюємо,
цілком можна думати про це саме так, і це дозволить нам провести паралель із
квантовою інформацією трохи пізніше.
Припустимо, що
класичний стан, який ми бачимо, — це класичний стан a, який може бути будь-яким станом у нашій множині сигма.
Це загалом змінює імовірнісний
стан X, принаймні з нашої точки зору.
Ймовірності більше не
мають жодного значення, оскільки тепер ми знаємо, який
класичний стан у X.
Це a, і більше немає
жодної невизначеності щодо цього.
Тому тепер ми скажемо так,
що ймовірність того, що система перебуває в стані a, дорівнює одиниці.
Ми знаємо це, тому що щойно подивилися на неї і побачили, що класичний стан — це a, тому новий імовірнісний стан X — це один
де ймовірність
перебування в класичному стані a дорівнює одиниці.
І цей імовірнісний стан представлений
вектором ймовірностей кет a.
Ми маємо одиницю на позиції, що відповідає класичному стану a, і нуль на всіх інших позиціях.
Наприклад, якщо ми знову
розглянемо ситуацію, де X — це біт і ми маємо той самий
імовірнісний стан, що й раніше,
тоді якщо ми виміряємо X, можемо уявити, що
відбувається перехід.
З ймовірністю три чверті ми бачимо класичний стан нуль, і шляхом вимірювання ми переходимо до кет нуль
як нашого імовірнісного стану,
а з ймовірністю одна чверть ми переходимо до кет один.
Ти можеш думати про це як про перехід знань, якщо хочеш, на противагу справжньому
фізичному переходу,
але важливо для цього уроку — зрозуміти, як працює математика.
Це насправді тривіально, але, визнаючи цю тривіальність, аналогічний опис
для квантового контексту
може здатися трохи менш таємничим.
Остання примітка полягає в тому, що для іншої людини, яка не бачила,
яким був класичний стан X, коли ми його виміряли,
імовірнісний стан
природно не зміниться в результаті того, що ми його виміряли.
Це нормально. Різні люди можуть
мати різні знання про конкретну систему і відповідно вибирати
різні імовірнісні стани,
щоб представляти своє
знання про цю систему.
В останній частині цього обговорення класичної інформації ми поговоримо про класичні операції, які можна виконати над системою,
починаючи з детерміністичних операцій.
Коли ми виконуємо операцію над системою, її стан загалом змінюється в результаті, і в цьому контексті слово «детерміністичний» означає,
що результат виконання
операції повністю залежить від того, в якому класичному
стані перебувала система
до виконання операції.
Іншими словами,
немає елементу випадковості, коли виконується детерміністична
операція, тобто немає ніякої випадковості
або невизначеності.
У математичних термінах детерміністичні операції
описуються функціями.
Кожна функція f вигляду,
який ти бачиш тут, що означає, що і вхід, і вихід функції
відповідають елементам
нашої множини класичних станів сигма, описує детерміністичну операцію.
Класичний стан a
перетворюється на стан f від a для кожного вибору стану a.
Для кожної функції f такого вигляду завжди буде унікальна матриця M, що задовольняє цій умові,
яку ти бачиш тут,
а саме: множення
M на вектор кет a дає нам вектор кет f від a,
і це справедливо для будь-якого
вибору класичного стану a.
Не так складно записати
явний опис M, враховуючи будь-яку функцію f
такого вигляду.
Вона завжди матиме рівно
одну одиницю в кожному стовпці, а всі інші елементи дорівнюватимуть нулю.
І ось формула. Елемент b, a матриці M дорівнює одиниці, якщо b дорівнює f від a,
а інакше дорівнює нулю, і під цим ми маємо на увазі,
що це елемент M, рядок якого відповідає b,
а стовпець відповідає a.
WEBVTT
Ми побачимо кілька прикладів через хвилину і зрозуміємо, чому ця формула працює.
Тепер може бути незрозуміло, навіщо нам хотілося б взяти функцію і виразити її у вигляді матриці,
але це має сенс. Одна з причин, і мабуть, головна, полягає в тому, що якщо у нас є система
в імовірнісному стані
і ми виконуємо детерміністичну
операцію над цією системою, то результуючий імовірнісний
стан можна отримати
шляхом матрично-векторного множення, тобто якщо наша система
перебуває в імовірнісному стані,
представленому
деяким вектором ймовірностей v, і ми виконуємо детерміністичну
операцію, описану матрицею M,
над цією системою, то результуючий імовірнісний стан визначатиметься як M, помножена на v.
Тут до речі ця стрілка з маленькою
рисочкою ось так — це лише поширена нотація в математиці для позначення того, як одна
річ відображається в
або перетворюється на іншу. Можна було б просто використовувати звичайну стрілку, але це є загальноприйнятим
і зрозумілим, і можливо, воно трохи точніше, ніж просто стрілка, яка може означати багато різних речей.
Тепер розглянемо приклад або набір прикладів, насправді.
Розглянемо, що відбувається, коли ми беремо нашу множину класичних станів сигма знову як бінарний алфавіт.
Не так вже й багато різних функцій того вигляду, який ми розглядали, коли це наша множина класичних станів, і якщо бути точнішим, є рівно чотири
функції такого вигляду.
Ось ці чотири функції описані за допомогою їх так званих таблиць значень.
Перша таблиця описує
першу функцію, яку ми назвали f1.
Для кожного можливого входу зліва ми вказуємо відповідний
вихід справа, отже f1 від нуля дорівнює нулю,
і f1 від одиниці, знову ж таки, дорівнює нулю, тобто f1 — це
константна нульова функція.
Вона завжди приймає значення нуль.
Друга функція f2
— це тотожна функція.
Вихід завжди дорівнює вхідному значенню, як видно з другої таблиці.
Третя функція f3 описується
третьою таблицею.
f3 від нуля дорівнює одиниці, а f3 від одиниці дорівнює нулю.
Ця функція більш відома
як функція НЕ або логічне заперечення.
Іноді ми також називаємо її бітовим переворотом, оскільки вона перетворює нуль
на одиницю, а одиницю на нуль.
Остання функція f4 — знову
константна функція, як і перша, але ця є константною одиничною функцією,
оскільки вона завжди приймає значення одиниця.
І це єдині чотири функції з бінарного алфавіту в себе.
Ось чотири матриці, що відповідають цим чотирьом функціям, описаним
формулою з раніше,
яку ти бачиш тут, і якщо хочеш, можеш поставити відео на паузу і перевірити це.
Просто пам'ятай, що для матриць порядок індексів завжди такий: спочатку рядки, потім стовпці.
Тому елемент b, a відповідає
рядку b і стовпцю a, або рядку, що відповідає
класичному стану b,
і стовпцю, що відповідає
класичному стану a.
Наприклад, якщо ми подивимося
на першу функцію, маємо: f1 від нуля дорівнює нулю,
і відповідно
елемент нуль, нуль матриці M1 дорівнює одиниці.
Ну, елемент один, нуль,
який знаходиться тут, дорівнює нулю, і можна зробити те саме для випадку,
де вхід дорівнює одиниці, і аналогічно для
інших трьох функцій.
Можна також перевірити, що ця
формула з раніше є істинною, і можна просто пройтись по всіх різних
можливостях, щоб перевірити це.
І насправді, якщо ти подумаєш про те, як
працює матричне множення, то в принципі можна просто приблизно оцінити це.
Коли ти множиш матрицю на вектор стандартного базису ось так, можна уявити, що
ти берешь вхідне значення
і «опускаєш» його на
верх однієї з матриць у стовпці, що відповідає
класичному стану
всередині кета, і вихід, який
отримуємо, — це просто той стовпець як вектор ймовірностей.
Наприклад, M3, помножена на кет
нуль, дає тобі нуль, один
як вектор ймовірностей, що є кет один.
M3, помножена на кет
один, дає тобі один, нуль, що є кет нуль, і так далі.
Ми більш детально розглянемо операції над
імовірнісними станами через хвилину, але спочатку введемо другу частину нотації Дірака.
Це буде корисно
для розмови про операції та розгляду їх як великих C, а також буде стандартним інструментом,
яким ми продовжимо користуватися надалі. Налаштування таке ж, як і раніше.
У нас є будь-яка множина класичних станів сигма, з якою ми працюємо, і ми припускаємо, що маємо якийсь спосіб
впорядкування цих класичних станів.
Тоді ми записуємо ось таку
конструкцію, де цього разу
кутова риска стоїть зліва, а не справа, що означає рядковий вектор з одиницею
на позиції, що
відповідає a, і нулем на всіх інших позиціях, що відповідають усім
іншим класичним станам.
Отже, різниця між
цією конструкцією і кет a полягає в тому, що ця є рядковим вектором, а
кет a — стовпцевим вектором,
WEBVTT
але в іншому вектори
визначаються схожим чином.
Ми читаємо це як бра a. Не знаю, чи це має бути смішним, але ідея полягає в тому, що назви бра і кет
— це дві половини слова «bracket» (дужка), і ми ще повернемося до цього через хвилину.
Але спочатку давай розглянемо
дуже швидкий приклад.
Для бінарного алфавіту маємо, що бра нуль — це
ось цей рядковий вектор, аналогічний кет a,
за винятком того, що це рядковий вектор
замість стовпцевого, а бра один — ось цей вектор.
Тепер загалом, якщо ми множимо рядковий
вектор на стовпцевий вектор, розглядаючи їх просто як матриці,
що мають лише
один рядок або лише один стовпець, то отримуємо матрицю один на один, яку можна
розглядати як скаляр.
Тут до речі слід
думати про ці зірочки як про довільні числа.
Зокрема, якщо
ми множимо рядковий вектор бра a на стовпцевий вектор кет b,
то можуть відбутися дві речі.
Перша — a і b рівні, тобто вони в одному класичному стані, і в цьому разі одиниці збіжаться
і добуток дорівнюватиме одиниці, або може бути так,
що a і b різні,
і тоді одиниці не збігаються, і добуток дорівнює нулю.
Простий спосіб виразити
ці спостереження — ось так.
І просто для охайності, ми записуємо цей добуток ось так, з лише однією рискою посередині, і це означає рівно те саме,
що й ось це.
І тепер ти бачиш, як
бра і кет поєднуються, утворюючи дужку, яка також
називається внутрішнім добутком,
і це дуже важлива річ, до якої ми повернемося
в уроці номер три.
Множення стовпцевого
вектора на рядковий вектор, з іншого боку, дає нам матрицю, як ти бачиш тут.
Наприклад, знову повертаючись
до бінарного алфавіту, якщо ми множимо кет нуль на бра нуль,
отримуємо ось цю матрицю, і можемо розглянути
інші можливості, щоб побачити, що відбувається.
Кет нуль, помножений на бра один, дає
ось цю матрицю, де одиниця тепер перемістилася
на цю позицію.
Кет один, бра нуль виглядає ось так, і ось кет один, бра один.
Ми бачимо, що є лише одна одиниця в матриці, яка в іншому складається суцільно з нулів, і позиція цієї одиниці
визначається тим, які
класичні стани ми вибираємо в бра і кеті.
Точніше, і
це справедливо загалом, для будь-якого вибору множини класичних станів матриця, яку ми отримуємо, множачи кет a на бра b,
— це матриця з одиницею на позиції a, b і нулем на всіх інших позиціях.
І тепер, маючи і першу, і другу частини нотації Дірака, ми маємо дуже зручний інструмент для зв'язку операцій з матрицями.
Тому ненадовго повернімося
до детерміністичних операцій і згадаємо, що трохи
раніше в уроці
було зазначено, що для кожної функції f
такого вигляду тут, ми маємо детерміністичну операцію, яка перетворює a у f від a
для кожного можливого класичного стану a. І ми сказали, що для
будь-якої такої функції завжди є унікальна
матриця M, що діє ось так
на стани стандартного базису.
Використовуючи нотацію Дірака, ми тепер можемо дуже легко виразити цю матрицю ось так,
і ми бачимо, як іноді
можна працювати з матрицями повністю
в рамках нотації Дірака,
без явного перетворення
у вектори та матриці у вигляді прямокутників із числами.
У цьому випадку можемо перевірити, що
потрібна формула є правильною, помноживши M на кет a.
Підставляємо наш
вираз для M ось так, і можемо прибрати дужки та «скласти» бра
b з кет a ось так.
Це тому що матричне
множення лінійне, в даному випадку за першим аргументом, і асоціативне, тому ми можемо прибрати дужки.
І тепер, пам'ятаючи, що ми маємо фіксоване a, про яке говоримо, підсумовуючи по всіх
можливих варіантах b,
ця дужка тут
завжди буде дорівнювати нулю, якщо b не дорівнює a, тому внеску в суму не буде,
а коли b дорівнює a, дужка буде дорівнювати одиниці, і нам залишиться
ось цей один доданок.
Це і є потрібна нам формула, і у нас є дуже гарний і простий спосіб виразити функцію у вигляді матриці.
Окрім детерміністичних операцій, є також операції, які
самі вносять випадковість або невизначеність щодо
класичного стану системи.
Ми використовуємо термін «імовірнісна операція» для позначення таких операцій, і якщо бути точним, коли ми говоримо «імовірнісна операція»,
ми маємо на увазі операції, які
можуть вносити випадковість, тому детерміністичні операції є фактично окремим випадком
імовірнісних операцій,
які просто
не вносять жодної випадковості.
Ось простий приклад, де
вноситься деяка випадковість.
Це операція над одним бітом. Вона працює так: якщо класичний стан
біта — нуль,
то нічого не відбувається. Біт залишається нулем, але якщо класичний
стан біта — одиниця, то операція перевертає біт до нуля
WEBVTT
з ймовірністю, рівною 1/2.
Для цієї операції немає спеціальної назви, принаймні, наскільки мені відомо.
Це просто приклад, але можна уявити, як виконувати
цю операцію над бітом.
Так само як детерміністичні операції, імовірнісні операції можуть
бути представлені матрицями, і їхній вплив на імовірнісні стани
визначається матрично-векторним множенням, як і раніше.
Цього разу матриці не обов'язково мають рівно одну одиницю в кожному стовпці, а решта — нулі.
Імовірнісні операції
більш загально представляються стохастичними матрицями.
Це матриці, всі елементи яких є
невід'ємними дійсними числами, і де елементи в
кожному стовпці в сумі дають одиницю.
Це рівнозначно тому, що
стохастичні матриці — це матриці, де кожен стовпець
утворює вектор ймовірностей.
Це має сенс, якщо подумати про
дію матриці на вектор стандартного базису.
Беремо будь-який
класичний стан і уявляємо, що «опускаємо» цей стан на верх матриці в тому стовпці, який відповідає
цьому класичному стану,
і цей стовпець говорить нам, яким є
імовірнісний стан, що виходить у вигляді вектора ймовірностей.
Імовірнісна операція
в нашому прикладі, наприклад, описується ось цією матрицею.
Якщо ми виконуємо цю операцію
над класичним станом нуль, то імовірнісний стан, який отримуємо, визначається першим стовпцем,
який знову є класичним станом нуль, або еквівалентно, імовірнісним
станом, де нуль зустрічається з ймовірністю одиниця.
Якщо замість цього ми виконуємо цю операцію над класичним станом один, то ми фактично просто рандомізуємо біт, і відповідно отримуємо
ось цей вектор ймовірностей
де ймовірність
кожного з можливих станів дорівнює 1/2.
Загалом, якщо ми виконуємо цю операцію над будь-яким імовірнісним станом, то ефект по суті
— це зважене середнє між двома стовпцями,
оскільки саме так і працює
матрично-векторне множення.
Воно лінійне, тому ми просто усереднюємо два
можливих результати відповідним чином.
Коли ми думаємо про імовірнісні
операції таким чином, природно думати про
них як про потенційне введення або впровадження випадковості.
Ми можемо просто читати стовпці один за одним і бачити випадковість,
яку вони вводять для кожного можливого класичного стану.
Також можна думати про
імовірнісні операції дещо по-іншому, а саме як про випадковий вибір детерміністичних операцій.
Наприклад, у нашому прикладі можна думати про цю операцію як про рівнозначну
підкиданню чесної монети
і або виконанню
константної нульової функції, або тотожної функції,
кожна з ймовірністю 1/2,
і ти можеш бачити це відображення
тут у цьому рівнянні.
Це завжди можливо для
будь-якої імовірнісної операції, і це досить інтуїтивно.
Якщо ти робив випадкові вибори
як частину якогось процесу, ти завжди міг уявити, що робиш ці випадкові вибори заздалегідь
і потім «закодовуєш» ці
вибори в деякий набір детерміністичних операцій.
Іноді буває дуже корисно думати про імовірнісні
операції саме так, і ми побачимо приклад
цього пізніше в парі уроків.
Останнє, що слід сказати
про класичну інформацію для цього уроку, стосується композиції
імовірнісних операцій, що просто означає виконання
однієї за одною.
Припустимо, що ми
маємо якусь систему під назвою X, і M1 через Mn — це стохастичні матриці, що представляють імовірнісні
операції над X.
Уяви спочатку, що маємо
вектор ймовірностей v, який представляє імовірнісний
стан X у певний момент, і потім спочатку застосовуємо
першу імовірнісну операцію до X, яка представлена матрицею M1, а потім застосовуємо другу
імовірнісну операцію,
яка представлена матрицею M2.
Якщо ми це робимо, то
вектор ймовірностей, який отримуємо після застосування лише першої
операції, — це M1, помножена на v,
а коли ми застосовуємо
другу операцію, результуючий вектор ймовірностей — це M2, помножена на будь-який вектор, який ми отримали
після застосування M1. Отже, це виглядає ось так.
Тепер матричне множення
— це асоціативна операція, що означає, що неважливо, де ми ставимо ці дужки.
Тому ми могли б так само
поставити дужки ось так.
Це дуже просто, але також цікаво, оскільки це показує, що ми
можемо думати про операцію, де спочатку застосовується M1,
а потім застосовується M2,
як про єдину операцію.
Іншими словами, імовірнісна операція, яку ми отримуємо шляхом композиції першої та
другої імовірнісних операцій, представлена
матричним добутком M2, помноженим на M1,
і це та сама операція незалежно від того, в якому імовірнісному
стані ми починали.
Нам не потрібно знати нічого про вектор ймовірностей v, щоб думати про цю складену операцію або описувати
її.
Зверни увагу, що порядок
тут такий: M2 зліва, а M1 справа, оскільки
матриця справа, M1,
— це та, що
множиться на вектор v, тоді як M2 множиться
на будь-який вектор, що ми отримуємо після множення на M1.
WEBVTT
Тому завжди потрібно пам'ятати, що порядок у певному
сенсі змінюється на протилежний.
Операція, яка виконується
першою, знаходиться справа, а операція, яка виконується останньою, або в цьому випадку другою,
знаходиться зліва.
Якщо ми не зупиняємося на другій операції і застосовуємо всі їх по порядку, починаючи з першої і закінчуючи останньою, тобто Mn,
то композиція всіх
цих операцій разом задається ось цим добутком,
який ти бачиш тут,
і ти бачиш, що порядок
знову ж таки змінений на протилежний з тієї ж причини, що й раніше.
Отже, коротко кажучи, композиції
імовірнісних операцій представляються добутками
стохастичних матриць, що їх представляють.
Пам'ятаючи, що це
порядок матриць у добутку.
Ти завжди отримаєш стохастичну матрицю, взявши добуток
стохастичних матриць ось так, і іноді ми висловлюємо цей факт
кажучи, що стохастичні
матриці замкнуті відносно множення, і це можна
думати так, що ти не можеш вийти за межі
множини стохастичних матриць
при їх множенні, оскільки множина замкнута.
Повертаючись до
порядку матриць у цьому добутку, важливо відзначити, що
порядок справді має значення.
Матричне множення не є комутативним. Якщо ти зміниш порядок
матриць у добутку, результат може змінитися,
і для цього не потрібно дивитися далі, ніж на детерміністичні
операції.
Ось простий приклад
двох стохастичних матриць, обидві з яких представляють
детерміністичні операції, де порядок має значення.
M1 представляє константну нульову функцію. Припускаємо, що ми уявляємо, що ці дві операції виконуються над бітами, так само як у попередньому прикладі.
M2 представляє операцію НЕ
або бітовий переворот.
Якщо ти спочатку виконуєш M1,
а потім M2, результат — ось ця матриця, яка представляє
константну одиничну функцію.
Якщо встановлюєш біт у нуль
і потім перевертаєш його, це те саме, що просто
встановити цей біт в одиницю.
З іншого боку, якщо спочатку виконуєш M2
і потім M1, результат ось такий,
і це має сенс, тому що якщо перевертаєш біт
і потім встановлюєш його у нуль, це те саме, що
просто встановити його у нуль.
Не мало значення, що ти перевернув його. Очевидно, ці дві
матриці не однакові, тому у нас є дуже
простий приклад, що показує,
що порядок має значення. Звичайно, це зовсім не дивно.
Ми всі знаємо, що порядок, в якому
виконуються операції, має значення, або принаймні може мати значення.
Наприклад, якщо ти запалюєш
сірник і потім дмухаєш на нього, результат дуже відрізняється
від того, якщо дмухнути на сірник спочатку,
а потім запалити. На цьому місці ми досить багато поговорили
про класичну інформацію, і тепер нарешті час
обговорити квантову інформацію.
І ми виявимо, що
математично кажучи, квантова інформація працює
дуже схожим чином до класичної інформації
з деякими ключовими відмінностями.
Перша ключова відмінність
знаходиться на початку — як ми визначаємо стан, в цьому випадку квантовий стан системи,
і в певному сенсі цей один вибір — як
ми визначаємо квантовий стан — значною мірою визначає, як
працює квантова інформація.
Ми також визначимо, як
працюють вимірювання та операції, і в наступному уроці розглянемо, як
квантова інформація працює не тільки для одиночних систем,
але й для множинних систем,
але ці речі насправді
доволі природно випливають із того, як визначено квантовий стан одиночної системи в
ізоляції.
Ось визначення. Квантовий стан системи представляється стовпцевим вектором, індекси якого поставлені
у відповідність до
класичних станів цієї системи.
Отже, ми припускаємо тут, що
система, про яку ми говоримо, має деяку множину класичних станів, так само як коли ми говорили
про класичну інформацію
та імовірнісні стани. Елементи вектора квантового стану
є комплексними числами, на відміну від імовірнісного випадку,
де елементи є
невід'ємними дійсними числами.
І цього разу сума квадратів модулів
елементів має дорівнювати одиниці, на відміну від того, що сума дорівнює одиниці
як в імовірнісному випадку.
Комплексні числа, що з'являються
у векторі квантового стану, іноді називаються амплітудами і відіграють роль,
схожу на ймовірності,
але вони не є ймовірностями і не мають
такого ж тлумачення.
Тепер я не можу дати тобі вагомої причини, чому квантові стани
мають визначатися саме так, окрім того, щоб сказати, що
фізики відкрили:
це визначення
є фізично доречним і дозволяє нам описувати та моделювати
квантово-механічні системи.
Іншими словами, ми вибираємо це визначення,
тому що воно працює, а не тому, що є
якісь конкретні причини, чому квантові стани мають
визначатися саме так.
Щодо
математики цього поняття квантового стану, перший крок до розуміння та роботи з ним — згадати це визначення
евклідової норми вектора, яку можна геометрично представити як довжину вектора, так само як ти б думав про довжину
двовимірного дійсного вектора, якщо намалював би його на аркуші
паперу як стрілку, що починається від початку координат звичайним чином.
WEBVTT
Зокрема, якщо маємо
стовпцевий вектор v ось так, який, як ми припускаємо, має
елементи з комплексними числами альфа один через альфа n,
тоді евклідова норма v визначається ось так.
Це нотація, яку ми
використовуємо для евклідової норми, ставлячи ці подвійні вертикальні риски навколо будь-якого вектора, про який ми говоримо.
У цьому випадку це v, і евклідова норма визначається як квадратний корінь із суми
квадратів модулів
елементів вектора.
Отже, інший спосіб визначити, що таке
вектор квантового стану, — це сказати, що вектор квантового стану — це стовпцевий вектор з
елементами з комплексних чисел,
евклідова норма якого дорівнює одиниці, тобто це одиничний вектор відносно евклідової норми.
Це тому, що сума
квадратів модулів дорівнює одиниці тоді і тільки тоді, коли евклідова
норма дорівнює одиниці.
Квадратний корінь нічого не змінює, коли сума квадратів
модулів дорівнює одиниці.
Отже, це і є вектор квантового стану. Це стовпцевий вектор з індексами, що відповідають класичним
станам системи,
з елементами з комплексних чисел і евклідовою нормою, що дорівнює одиниці.
Що це означає або що це передбачає, або як ми маємо інтерпретувати це
поняття — окреме питання, і в певному сенсі
вивчення квантової
інформації та обчислень — це дослідження того, що
це визначення передбачає, принаймні з точки зору
обробки інформації.
Це просто відправна точка.
Між іншим, зауважу, що існують
інші так звані норми, крім евклідової, і ця нотація тут
з подвійними рисками
навколо вектора не завжди
означає евклідову норму.
У різних контекстах ця нотація може відноситися
до іншої норми.
Наприклад, сума
модулів без квадратів або квадратного кореня — це інша норма,
яку часто називають одиничною нормою. Насправді існує досить багато
різних норм.
Іноді ти бачитимеш,
що ця нотація використовується з нижнім індексом після
другої пари рисок, що надає більше інформації про те, яку норму ми маємо на увазі.
І коли ми це робимо, досить типово, що цифра два як нижній індекс
означає евклідову норму.
Але в цьому курсі, коли б ми не мали
стовпцевого вектора ось так, ця нотація з подвійними рисками самостійно
означає евклідову норму.
Ось кілька прикладів
векторів квантового стану, і ці конкретні вектори квантового стану є векторами стану qubit,
що означає, що
класичні стани нашої системи — нуль і один.
Слово qubit є скороченням від «квантовий біт», що насправді є лише бітом,
який може перебувати в квантовому стані.
Перші два приклади дуже прості. Вектори стандартного базису
кет нуль і кет один є векторами квантового стану.
Вони обидва є стовпцевими векторами, і індекси відповідають
класичним станам нуль і один, і елементи цих
векторів є комплексними числами.
Для цих конкретних векторів елементи — нуль і один, що є дійсними числами, і фактично цілими числами, але вони також є комплексними числами,
у яких
уявна частина дорівнює нулю.
Кожен вектор має один елемент, що дорівнює одиниці, і один елемент, що дорівнює нулю.
Тому коли ми підсумовуємо квадрати модулів
елементів, ми отримуємо одиницю в обох випадках.
Отже, умови,
необхідні для того, щоб ці вектори були векторами квантового стану, виконані.
Наступні два приклади — дуже часто зустрічані стани qubit, що називаються плюс-станом і мінус-станом.
Вони позначаються, як
ти бачиш тут на екрані, або як кет плюс
або кет мінус ось так, і вони визначаються так, як ти бачиш тут.
Знову ж таки, елементи цих
векторів є комплексними числами. Цього разу вони або плюс один, поділений на квадратний корінь із двох, або мінус один, поділений на квадратний корінь із двох,
і коли ми підсумовуємо
квадрати модулів, отримуємо 1/2 плюс 1/2, що дорівнює одиниці.
До речі, ставити
знак плюс або знак мінус всередину кета ось так
може здаватися трохи дивним, оскільки це не класичні
стани нашої системи,
але ця нотація все одно використовується, і ми повернемося до цього за мить.
Але поки що, коротко кажучи, ми можемо використовувати нотацію Дірака, щоб помістити будь-яку назву вектора всередину кета.
Вектор не має бути
вектором стандартного базису, коли ми використовуємо нотацію Дірака.
Ось останній приклад стану qubit
на цей момент.
Це вектор квантового стану qubit, який не має спеціальної назви і не є особливо значущим.
Елементи цього вектора — це один плюс два помножених на i,
поділений на три, та мінус 2/3.
Це комплексні числа, і якщо ти обчислиш
квадрати модулів цих двох елементів, ти отримаєш 5/9 для першого
і 4/9 для другого. Тому сума квадратів
модулів дорівнює одиниці.
І ось останній приклад. Цього разу для системи,
класичні стани якої — чотири масті карт.
Я не знаю, навіщо нам мати систему, класичні стани якої —
чотири масті карт, яка перебуває в квантовому стані, але це можливо в принципі
і це просто як приклад.
WEBVTT
Елементи, що відповідають
різним мастям: 1/2 для трефів, мінус
i, поділений на два, для бубен,
нуль для червоних, оскільки вони не з'являються в сумі, та один, поділений на квадратний
корінь із двох, для пік.
І ось як це виглядає
у вигляді стовпцевого вектора, припускаючи, що ми впорядкували
класичні стани, як робили раніше,
тобто в порядку,
який ти бачиш тут.
Взявши квадрати модулів
цих елементів, отримуємо одну чверть для першого, також одну чверть для наступного.
Квадрат модуля
нуля дорівнює нулю, тому цей елемент не
вносить внеску до суми.
І нарешті, для останнього отримуємо 1/2. Отже, сума дорівнює одиниці, що й вимагається від цього вектора,
щоб бути вектором квантового стану.
Буквально хвилину тому ми використали нотацію
кет плюс і кет мінус для позначення двох векторів стану qubit, які не є векторами стандартного базису.
І я хотів би повернутися
до цього моменту ненадовго і пояснити, як нотація Дірака використовується для довільних векторів, а не лише для векторів стандартного базису.
Як я вже згадував, ми можемо використовувати будь-яку назву,
яку хочемо, всередині бра або кета, щоб позначити вектор.
Кети є стовпцевими векторами,
а бра — рядковими, як і раніше.
Як приклад, грецька буква
псі дуже часто використовується всередині кета для позначення довільного вектора,
і тут ми використовуємо її, щоб
дати назву вектору стану з раніше, який не
має спеціальної назви.
Коли ми робимо це, літера псі не
обов'язково має якесь самостійне значення.
Це просто назва вектора, і вона всередині кета, щоб допомогти нам уточнити,
що це стовпцевий вектор.
Це може бути
трохи заплутаним іноді, і є потенціал для неоднозначності, якщо літера псі могла б бути пов'язана
з класичним станом
деякої системи, наприклад, але загалом це не
спричиняє жодних проблем, і ти не зобов'язаний використовувати
нотацію Дірака ось так,
якщо не хочеш. Використання рядкових літер, таких
як u, v або w, без кета — це також чудовий спосіб
позначати стовпцевий вектор,
або точніше,
вектор квантового стану.
Твій вибір — яку нотацію
використовувати для вираження.
Тобі просто потрібно переконатися, що по-перше, значення того, що
ти намагаєшся висловити, зрозуміле іншим.
І по-друге, що ти розумієш те, що
інші намагаються висловити, навіть коли їхні уподобання щодо нотації не збігаються з твоїми.
Є одне дуже важливе правило використання нотації Дірака
для довільних векторів, а саме: якщо маєш стовпцевий вектор,
який ти вирішив записати
як кет псі, наприклад, або це може бути інша
назва всередині кета, тоді рядковий вектор бра псі
розуміється як
спряжений транспонований вектора кет псі.
І тут це записано як рівняння, де цей «кинджал» тут позначає спряжене транспонування.
Конкретно це
рядковий вектор, який отримуємо, по-перше, транспонуючи вектор, тобто перекладаємо вектор на бік і змінюємо його зі стовпця на рядок,
не змінюючи самих елементів. І по-друге, беручи комплексне спряження
кожного з елементів.
Можна насправді виконати
ці дві операції — транспонування і
поелементне комплексне спряження — в будь-якому порядку, бо
ці дві операції комутують.
Отже, для вектора в цьому прикладі, враховуючи, що ми вирішили
назвати цей вектор кет псі, розуміється, що бра псі
означає ось цей вектор
де ми транспонували вектор, перетворивши кет нуль і кет
один на бра нуль і бра один, і взяли комплексне
спряження кожного елемента,
ось чому один плюс
два помножених на i, поділений на три перетворюється на один мінус два
помножених на i, поділений на три тут.
Ось як ці вектори виглядають, коли вони записані
явно як стовпцевий вектор і рядковий вектор.
Зверни увагу, до речі, що
це правило узгоджується з нотацією, яку ми використовуємо, коли маємо класичні стани
всередині бра і кета.
У такому випадку елементи
усі нулі, крім однієї одиниці, і тому комплексне
спряження нічого не змінює в цьому випадку.
Ми тепер побачили, як квантові стани представляються у вигляді векторів, але поки незрозуміло, яке значення або які наслідки це має
з точки зору того, що
можна зробити з системою в квантовому стані або як можна взаємодіяти з нею.
Перше, що нам потрібно зробити, щоб прояснити ці питання,
— обговорити вимірювання.
Інтуїтивно кажучи,
вимірювання забезпечують механізм для вилучення класичної
інформації з квантових систем.
Коли ми дивимося на систему,
коли вона перебуває в квантовому стані, ми не бачимо квантовий стан, так само як ми не бачимо
імовірнісні стани,
ми бачимо класичні стани, і саме поняття вимірювання й забезпечує цей інтерфейс.
Якщо ми, як люди, хочемо щось дізнатися про квантову систему, ми маємо виміряти її, і роблячи це, ми витягнемо класичну інформацію
про той квантовий
стан, у якому перебувала система.
Існують різні
поняття вимірювань. Різниця полягає справді в загальності, і ми почнемо з найпростішого і найосновнішого,
яке зазвичай називається
вимірюванням у стандартному базисі.
WEBVTT
Ми узагальнимо це
в наступних уроках. Ми поговоримо про так звані
проективні вимірювання в уроці три, а потім пізніше в
третьому розділі курсу
поговоримо про загальні вимірювання, які також називаються мірами з позитивним оператором-значенням, або POVM скорочено.
Але поки ми обмежимо увагу вимірюваннями у стандартному базисі.
Коли вимірювання
виконується над системою, буде деяка множина
можливих результатів цього вимірювання, які є класичними результатами,
і у випадку
вимірювання у стандартному базисі ці можливі результати — це
саме класичні стани будь-якої системи, яка вимірюється.
Кожен із цих класичних станів буде результатом вимірювання з певною ймовірністю, і ця ймовірність — квадрат модуля
елемента, що відповідає
цьому класичному стану будь-якого вектора квантового стану,
у якому система перебувала безпосередньо перед вимірюванням.
Ми знаємо, що квадрат модуля будь-якого комплексного числа — це невід'ємне дійсне число, і ми знаємо з визначення
векторів квантового стану,
що сума квадратів модулів елементів вектора квантового стану дорівнює одиниці.
Тому це має сенс. Кожен класичний стан з'явиться як результат
вимірювання з певною ймовірністю, і ймовірності в сумі дають одиницю.
Ось кілька прикладів. По-перше, припустимо, що маємо
qubit в плюс-стані.
Якщо ми виміряємо цей qubit щодо
вимірювання у стандартному базисі, ми отримуємо або нуль, або
одиницю як результат.
Ймовірність отримати нуль — це квадрат модуля одного, поділеного на квадратний корінь із двох, що дорівнює 1/2, і та сама
ймовірність отримати одиницю.
Тобто якщо виміряєш плюс-стан, отримаєш рівномірний випадковий біт.
Якщо система перебуває в мінус-стані,
а не в плюс-стані, то вимірювання працює
рівно так само.
Ймовірності знову 1/2 для кожного можливого результату.
Єдина відмінність тут у тому, що знак плюс змінився на мінус, але коли ми беремо модуль,
нічого не змінюється.
Якщо ми виміряємо цей стан qubit, ймовірність отримати результат нуль — це квадрат модуля одного плюс два помножених на i,
поділеного на три, що дорівнює 5/9,
і ймовірність отримати результат один — це квадрат модуля
мінус 2/3, що дорівнює 4/9.
І нарешті, вимірювання
стандартного базисного стану кет нуль дає результат
нуль з певністю, і аналогічно вимірювання стану кет один
дає результат один з певністю. Це тому, що квадрат модуля одиниці дорівнює одиниці.
Подібно до того, що ми мали в
імовірнісному контексті. Ми можемо пов'язати ці квантові
стани — кет нуль і кет один — з тим, що система перебуває в
цих класичних станах,
і цей приклад узгоджується
з таким тлумаченням.
Тепер, так само як в
імовірнісному контексті, якщо ми виміряємо систему, коли
вона перебуває в квантовому стані,
стан загалом зміниться в результаті виконання
цього вимірювання.
Зокрема, і знову ж таки, це точно так само, як ми мали
в імовірнісному контексті.
Якщо ми виміряємо систему і результат вимірювання
— класичний стан a, то новий квантовий стан
системи стає кет a.
Тому для цього стану тут,
наприклад, ми бачимо такий самий вид
поведінки, що й в імовірнісному контексті.
Якщо ми виміряємо, то з ймовірністю 5/9 отримаємо результат нуль, у цьому випадку стан
переходить до кет нуль,
і з ймовірністю
4/9 результат — одиниця, і стан переходить до кет один.
Іноді це явище називається «колапсом»
квантового стану, і це те, від чого люди,
що вивчають основи
квантової механіки, не можуть спати вночі.
Але з чисто
математичної точки зору це досить просто
і дуже аналогічно тому, що ми маємо в імовірнісному випадку.
Джерело напруги тут у певному сенсі стосується фундаментальної
природи квантових станів і того, що вони представляють, та як вони відрізняються
від імовірнісних станів. Але на математичному рівні це, мабуть, те, чого варто було б очікувати.
Зверни увагу, до речі, що якщо
ти вимірюєш вдруге, то отримаєш точно
такий самий результат, що й при першому вимірюванні.
Тому є обмеження на те, скільки класичної інформації можна витягти з квантового стану, і ми повернемося до цього незабаром
в іншому уроці. Ми говорили про квантові стани, а також про вимірювання, зокрема про вимірювання у стандартному базисі,
які забезпечують спосіб
витягти класичну інформацію з квантових станів.
Тема, що залишилася для
цього уроку, — операції, зокрема унітарні операції, які описують, як квантові стани систем
можуть змінюватися. Природно, оскільки вектори квантового стану відрізняються від векторів ймовірностей, можна очікувати, що множина допустимих операцій
над квантовими станами відрізняється від того, що ми маємо для
класичної інформації, і справді це так.
Тоді як операції над імовірнісними станами представляються стохастичними матрицями, операції над векторами квантового стану
представляються унітарними матрицями.
Ось визначення унітарних матриць.
Квадратна матриця U з елементами з
комплексних чисел є унітарною, якщо вона задовольняє рівностям,
які ти бачиш тут.
WEBVTT
«Кинджал» означає
спряжене транспонування, яке ми вже бачили для векторів, коли говорили про нотацію Дірака кілька хвилин тому.
Тут ми виконуємо
спряжене транспонування матриці, а не вектора, але по суті це те саме.
Ми транспонуємо матрицю, що просто означає, що
ми міняємо рядки та стовпці місцями, тому елемент JK стає елементом KJ,
а також беремо комплексне
спряження кожного елемента.
Також ця нотація тут
означає одинична матриця.
Ці дві рівності тут
насправді еквівалентні. Якщо маєш одну, то
автоматично маєш і другу.
Обидві рівнозначні
тому, що U є оборотною, і обернена матриця дорівнює
спряженій транспонованій.
Це справедливо лише для квадратних
матриць, до речі. Якщо маєш матрицю, яка не є квадратною, то одна з цих двох
рівностей може бути істинною,
але тоді друга не буде істинною.
Але тут ми говоримо
про квадратні матриці.
Отже, це стандартне
визначення унітарних матриць, і воно зручне, оскільки легко перевірити,
чи є матриця унітарною.
Потрібно лише помножити матрицю на її спряжену транспоновану з обох сторін і перевірити,
чи виходить одинична матриця.
Є рівнозначний спосіб охарактеризувати унітарні матриці, а саме: квадратна матриця є унітарною тоді і тільки тоді, коли вона ніколи не змінює евклідову норму
жодного вектора при множенні. Матриця N×N U є унітарною тоді і тільки тоді, коли евклідова норма U, помноженого на v,
дорівнює евклідовій нормі v для кожного n-вимірного стовпцевого вектора v з елементами з комплексних чисел.
Тому якщо v — це
вектор квантового стану, то U, помножена на v, також є
вектором квантового стану, оскільки вектори квантового стану
— це просто вектори з
евклідовою нормою, що дорівнює одиниці.
Фактично, можна сказати трохи більше, а саме: унітарні матриці — це саме ті матриці, які завжди перетворюють вектори квантового стану
на вектори квантового стану. Це схожа ситуація до тієї, яку ми маємо для стохастичних матриць
і векторів ймовірностей.
Стохастичні матриці
— це саме ті матриці, які завжди перетворюють вектори ймовірностей на вектори ймовірностей.
Отже, як тільки ми вирішили, що операції мають представлятися матрицями, що рівнозначно твердженню, що перетворення лінійно діють
на вектори, що представляють стани, ці вибори множин допустимих операцій виникають природно, принаймні
у математичному сенсі.
Тепер розглянемо приклади унітарних операцій над qubit.
Ми побачимо набагато більше прикладів
унітарних операцій у наступних уроках, включаючи унітарні операції в системах
з більш ніж двома класичними станами. Але поки зосередимося лише
на унітарних операціях над qubit.
Ми будемо бачити ці
конкретні приклади знову і знову, тому точно варто
познайомитися з цими операціями.
Перша група прикладів — так звані операції Паулі.
Це операції, що відповідають матрицям Паулі, які показані тут.
Вони всі унітарні, і можна перевірити це для кожної відповідно до визначення з раніше.
Ці конкретні матриці
рівні своїм власним спряженим транспонованим, тобто вони є
ермітовими матрицями.
Тому перевірка того, що вони
всі унітарні, в цьому випадку полягає в тому, щоб підвести в квадрат кожну і переконатися, що результат
— одинична матриця.
Назви, які ти бачиш для цих
матриць, є досить стандартними, і ти також побачиш
сигма x, сигма y та сигма z, які просто називаються X, Y та Z.
Але знай, що
великі літери X, Y та Z також часто використовуються для інших цілей, навіть у контексті
квантової інформації,
але вони є дуже поширеними
назвами для цих матриць.
Операція сигма x, або X,
також називається бітовим переворотом або операцією НЕ, яку ми вже бачили
в класичному контексті.
А операція сигма z, або Z,
також називається фазовим переворотом.
І тут ти бачиш
дію цих операцій на вектори стандартного базису, що певною мірою пояснює,
звідки беруться ці назви.
Безумовно, має сенс
називати сигма x бітовим переворотом на основі цієї дії тут.
Вона просто перевертає біт з
нуля до одиниці або з одиниці до нуля.
Також має сенс
називати сигма z фазовим переворотом на основі цієї дії тут.
Але якщо це не зовсім зрозуміло
зараз, нічого страшного.
Ми зустрічатимемо цю
операцію знову і знову, і значення
ставлення знаку мінус перед базисним вектором кет один, а не кет нуль,
і чому це називається фазовим переворотом, стане більш зрозумілим пізніше.
Наступний приклад —
операція Hadamard, яка представлена
ось цією матрицею, яку майже завжди позначають H.
Перевірка того, що H є унітарною, — це знову
пряме обчислення, яке, якщо я відступлю убік, ти можеш побачити тут.
Подібно до матриць Паулі, H є власною спряженою транспонованою.
Тому маємо ось цю рівність, і виконуючи множення, отримуємо одиничну матрицю, як і вимагається.
WEBVTT
Третій приклад — насправді цілий клас унітарних операцій,
відомих як фазові операції.
Це операції,
представлені будь-якою матрицею, що має ось такий вигляд, де тета — будь-яке дійсне число.
Тому цей елемент тут завжди буде деяким комплексним числом на одиничному колі.
Матриці такого вигляду завжди є унітарними, що я залишаю тобі для перевірки.
Цього разу спряжена транспонована не буде рівна вихідній матриці, якщо тільки це число тут не виявиться одиницею або мінус одиницею,
у цьому випадку отримаємо
або одиничну матрицю, або сигма z, які ми
вже зустрічали.
Зокрема, транспонування
нічого не зробить з цією матрицею, але взяття комплексного
спряження кожного елемента змінить цей елемент тут
на e в мінус i тета.
Ці дві конкретні операції тут є особливо важливими
прикладами фазових операцій.
Для першої ми беремо
тета рівним пі, поділеному на два, і отримуємо ось цю матрицю.
Це зазвичай називається
операцією S або gate S, коли ми говоримо про circuit, про який ми не говоримо в цьому уроці,
але це важлива
тема, яка незабаром підніметься.
Друга — ось ця операція. Це операція T або gate T.
І для неї тета
дорівнює пі, поділеному на чотири. Тому, обчислюючи експоненту, отримуємо ось це значення, що є один плюс i,
поділений на квадратний корінь із двох.
Ось кілька швидких прикладів, щоб побачити пару цих
операцій у дії.
Ось дія
операції Hadamard на кет нуль і кет один.
Якщо виконати
матрично-векторне множення, то побачимо, що ми отримуємо плюс-стан і
мінус-стан відповідно.
Якщо виконати операцію Hadamard на плюс-стані та
мінус-стані, з іншого боку, ми повертаємося до кет нуль і кет один.
Тому якщо трохи прибрати, можна побачити дію більш чітко.
Операція Hadamard
перетворює туди і назад між нульовим станом і плюс-станом, і між одиничним станом
і мінус-станом.
Щодо цих двох рівнянь тут, зверни увагу, що це дає нам простий спосіб виявити різницю між плюс-станом і мінус-станом.
Як ми бачили раніше в уроці, якщо ми виміряємо плюс-стан і мінус-стан відносно
вимірювання у стандартному базисі,
ми отримуємо рівномірний випадковий біт в обох випадках, що не допомагає нам
виявити різницю.
Але якщо виконаємо операцію Hadamard і потім виміряємо, побачимо нуль, якщо
вихідний стан був плюс-станом,
і одиницю, якщо вихідний
стан був мінус-станом.
Тобто ці два стани справді різні, і їх можна ідеально розрізнити
методом, який я щойно описав,
а саме спочатку виконати
операцію Hadamard і потім виміряти.
Повертаючись до прикладу
стану qubit, який ми бачили раніше і який не є особливо спеціальним, можна побачити, що операція Hadamard робить зі станом,
перетворюючи до форм,
які ти бачиш тут, і виконуючи множення.
І ось результат,
який можна перетворити назад у нотацію Дірака за бажанням,
і це один спосіб обчислити
такі дії.
Ось інший приклад, що ілюструє, що не завжди потрібно явно переводити у форму матриця-вектор.
Можна також виконувати ці
обчислення безпосередньо за допомогою нотації Дірака.
Цей приклад стосується операції T, і ось вона тут
просто для довідки.
Ця операція має ось таку дію на стани стандартного базису.
І якщо ми хочемо обчислити
дію операції T на плюс-стан, наприклад, можемо почати з розкриття
визначення плюс-стану
і потім використати лінійність,
щоб виразити результат ось так.
Тепер можемо просто підставити
ці вирази вгорі, зробити лише невелике спрощення для другого доданку, і ми отримуємо результат.
Якщо з якоїсь причини ми хочемо застосувати операцію Hadamard
до результату, можемо зробити схожу річ.
Спочатку підставляємо вираз для T, що діє на плюс-стан, і використовуємо лінійність, як робили раніше.
І тепер, якщо підставимо
вирази, які вже маємо для операції Hadamard,
що діє на кет нуль і кет один,
отримаємо ось це. І тепер можемо розкрити плюс-стан і мінус-стан, щоб отримати ось цей вираз,
який можна спростити просто додаванням, і ось кінцевий результат.
Немає нічого особливо
спеціального в цьому прикладі. Він просто покликаний
проілюструвати цей альтернативний, але рівнозначний спосіб
обчислення дій
цих операцій. Можна використовувати той
спосіб, який більш зручний у конкретній ситуації.
Одна остання примітка про
унітарні операції: композиції унітарних
операцій представляються матричним множенням
так само як в імовірнісному контексті, тобто можна обчислити дію послідовності унітарних операцій,
просто перемноживши
матриці між собою. І те, що отримаєш, —
це єдина унітарна матриця, що представляє сукупну дію
WEBVTT
послідовності операцій.
Так само як для стохастичних матриць, унітарні матриці
замкнуті відносно множення, тому завжди отримаєш унітарну матрицю,
коли компонуєш унітарні операції.
Потрібно переконатися,
що матриці перемножені в правильному порядку.
Але спосіб, яким це працює, — такий самий, як і для
стохастичних операцій, де матриця для першої операції, яку ти виконуєш,
завжди з'являтиметься в правій частині
матричного добутку, а остання — в лівій частині.
Тому, як і раніше, порядок змінений на протилежний у тому сенсі, що композиція йде справа наліво, а не зліва направо.
Ось цікавий приклад, що дає операцію, відому як операція «квадратний корінь із НЕ».
Припустимо, що спочатку
застосовуємо операцію Hadamard, потім операцію S, потім ще одну операцію Hadamard.
Сукупна дія
цих трьох операцій описується цим добутком.
Ось перша операція Hadamard, ось операція S, і ось друга операція Hadamard.
Якщо виконати матричне множення, яке тут явно не показане, але можна зробити самостійно за бажанням,
результат — ось ця матриця. Це унітарна матриця, і можна або перевірити це безпосередньо,
або довіритися тому факту, що унітарні матриці
замкнуті відносно множення.
Вона має бути унітарною, тому що ці три матриці є унітарними, як ми вже бачили.
У нас немає жодного конкретного
вектора квантового стану на думці тут.
Можна уявити, що виконуємо
цю послідовність операцій над будь-яким вектором квантового стану, і ця матриця описує дію.
Причина, чому ця сукупна операція, тобто та, яку описує ось ця матриця, називається операцією «квадратний корінь із НЕ»,
полягає в тому, що виконавши її
двічі, ми отримаємо операцію НЕ, або, іншими словами,
сигма x, або операцію X.
Виконання операції
двічі представляється зведенням матриці в квадрат або
множенням її на себе.
І якщо це зробиш, побачиш, що результат
— матриця Паулі x.
І це дещо дивно, і це дає тобі лише натяк на те, що можна робити деякі цікаві речі з квантовою інформацією, яких не можна робити з
класичною інформацією.
Немає класичної операції, тобто такої, що представлена
стохастичною матрицею, яка дає нам операцію НЕ,
якщо виконати її двічі.
Тому це гарний приклад, що показує, що квантові операції
поводяться дуже відмінно від класичних операцій.
І на цьому урок перший закінчується. У цьому уроці ми розглянули, як квантова інформація працює для одиночних систем в ізоляції,
і в наступному уроці поговоримо про те, як
квантова інформація працює для множинних систем.
Дякую за перегляд. Якщо є запитання, сміливо залишай їх у
розділі коментарів нижче.